good morning yes there is some windy
weather but there's also a bad crash in
the southeast valley now most of your
freeways are in excellent shape
but we're told now by metro police that
the closure of southbound boulder
highway tropicana
because of an auto pedestrian crash with
one person
in critical condition at this hour
southbounders on boulder highway coming
up on trop
you're going to be turned around here's
a live picture that we have from the
scene
a photographer armando is out there and
he's been checking it out for us
we understand that the road is
completely closed and there it is with
the
convenience store there and metro police
looks like they may be taking down
some of the yellow tape there so
hopefully that would be a good sign
that the traffic may be reopening we
also have a
traffic camera on the scene let's go
ahead and go back to the traffic
computer
so there are the folks who are
southbound on boulder highway being
turned around
and they are now being redirected back
northbound so here's what you do
if you are southbound you come up on
that closure
just go over they turn you back around
go west on trop to nellis
south on nellis all the way down to
russell road that will eventually take
you back to boulder highway if that's
your ultimate destination
now you're gonna lose about five to ten
minutes through there but i guess that's
better than being completely soft once
again
a auto pedestrian crash with one person
in critical condition